[Musique]
enfin bon ça les panneaux en fibres ont
juste et puis il ya des bruits de l'eau
douce ou pas la densité profond chez les
trois enfants à la densité le ciel du
travail - est le seul du polisario
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur la côte ouest de la réunion la
pointe au sel est un site remarquable
théâtre de la grande aventure de sel
réunionnais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
battus par les tempêtes cette pointe
basaltiques déchiqueté souffle et
résiste elle est protégée par un récif
corallien aux eaux claires et
poissonneuse dans la teneur en sel est
une des plus fortes du monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout ce matos
situé sous le vent avec un climat chaud
et sec des savanes accueilli une flore
et une faune typique
ce qui est intéressant la pointe au sel
c'est qu'on peut lire très facilement
le gradient de salinité puisque plus on
s'éloigne évidemment de la mer plus le
jet d'embrun rétrécit se réduit et donc
on a un gradient de végétation qui
reflète totalement l'appauvrissement
progressif en s'éloignant de la mer en
selle des milieux à 30 50 mètres de
celle ne joue plus et l'on va passer à
une végétation fortement entreprises et
c'est à dire fortement modifiée par
l'homme en particulier par par le
pâturage et bien c'est un paysage de
savane qui historiquement un recouvrait
entouraient le site de la pointe au sel
ce paysage de savane et bien il faut lui
associer les troupeaux des troupeaux de
chèvres et puis surtout des troupeaux de
bovins un des beaux mots cas avec une
bosse qui était vraiment l'image en fête
traditionnelle du pastoralisme du
pâturage à la réunion dans ces régions
sèches de bord de mer
[Musique]
la plupart des animaux fait qu'ils
vivent à la réunion ne subissent pas
directement la contrainte du sel
ils vont à subir indirectement pour ce
qui est de
de la végétation qui est elle même liée
à haut taux de salinité
donc là encore une fois les animaux sont
adaptés aux parties salines à travers la
végétation et non pas directement par
leur biologie sur cette végétation vient
se greffer des animaux qui sont donc
inféodés à chacune de ces parties sur
l'affectation rasoir trouver des petits
trucs et sur la végétation intermédiaire
va retrouver des sauterelles des
papillons et sur la savane on va
retrouver des espèces qui sont
classiques on va retrouver également
ailleurs
[Musique]
et
m
non
[Applaudissements]
au xviiie siècle les premiers colons
breton bâti ce morceau de côte pointe de
bretagne en raison de certaines
ressemblances avec les côtes
armoricaines il remarque que le climat
de la région et plus particulièrement de
cette pointe est idéal pour la
production salines après les tempêtes
les habitants dépôts viennent récupérer
le sel dans les anfractuosités des
roches une autre technique consiste à
faire évaporer l'eau de mer dans des
feuilles de palmiste adaptant ainsi des
gestes de guérande ou de noir entier
[Musique]
l'endroit le plus commode pour faire du
sel en l'île de bourbon et la grande
pointe où les habitants le font quand
ils en ont besoin
la manière dont il le foot et de prendre
de grandes feuilles de baliste desquels
ils font des vaisseaux plaz là on nomme
en pondre la base de bestioles des
feuilles de palme liste on achète les
encombre au bord de la mer afin de faire
du self pour cela on en place un grand
nombre
à côté les uns les autres sur la plage
et on les remplit d'eau de mer qu'on
remplace à mesure qu'elle s'évapore
jusqu'à ce qu'on ait une suffisante
quantité des cristaux ont fait dans les
enfants du pareil c'est bien chargé de
ça lui met dedans ça lui arrive bah oui
parce que je sens poindre la mer direct
pour le trop de temps dès cette époque
compte tenu de cette situation
exceptionnelle la pointe de bretagne ce
site des projets d'installation de salah
on sait que quatre salines fonctionner
au début du 20e siècle à la possession à
grandfonds près de saint gilles à la
pointe au sel et à l'étang salé
toutes sont situés sur le versant sec de
l'île avec sa lunette ont salué plus
grands challenges il existait mais après
sa longue retenue la pj prochaine citons
une pointe à la mer
il fait tout bien sûr qu'ils aillent
tous avec le blocus imposé par la
seconde guerre mondiale la réunion
manque de tout en réponse à la pénurie
de sel etienne du sac propriétaire du
domaine sucrier de stella matutina
décide la construction de salins à la
pointe au sel en 1940 au mama la paix et
les tontines des vers à manger salle
dans le panier le fort quand les
individus ville de chalon en engageant
blanc qui viennent chez cuit le panier
de la gagne et de celle de ne pas y
rester sept sages dans le panier du
maraîcher par rapport à des salines je
dirais comme guérande ou les salins du
midi ce sont des salines
donc en pente où on est obligé de pomper
l'eau de mer et ce n'est pas une des
salines naturel pour mieux c'était un
euro après une dans le bassin des
connotations le marché dégradations il
faut vous fait montre la densité au loup
il va prouver après sharon et luis
quelque chose qu'il ya eu des dents à
pauillac intelligente c'est tout le
poulpe a continuellement fait entendre
gueuler petit à petit
- nous attendrit les familles la
nourrice et à l'échelle etienne du cert
produit environ 250 tonnes de sel par an
jusqu'au début des années 50 mais
l'armistice de 1945 et la concurrence de
madagascar et de l'île maurice rendu
l'exploitation déficitaire
les salines cesse alors leurs activités
au début des années 60 le neveu
détiennent du sac
monsieur pâris leclerc hérite des
salines et les exploitent de nouveaux
plans en mutation monsieur pâris leclerc
fait alors remettre les bassins en état
relance la production de sel sur le site
et passent des contrats avec la
compagnie marseillaise de madagascar
pour commercialiser le sellering né en
1961 quand on commence à retrouver alors
mais l'avait trentaine de personnes qui
travaillent nos dames le marché
immobilier dans les cages récompense
avec la manche en compte les accidents
après la cession à magna et pour essayer
de lui parce qu'on ne peut pas avait eu
le plastique la mieux placée est seule
maintenant je n'oublie pas que je veux
bien y avoir habité personnes tout
puissant d'affaires avait quand même six
personnes sept personnes tous les mois
tu es payé mais j'ai quand même pas
beaucoup d'emphase en ces temps là des
fois tu prends les en rester là pendant
que beaucoup de salles polluer nous
n'irons dans le matin et l'après midi
ils se sont jurés trois personnes
il en a même
nous verrons ce que nous en dira le seul
avec le râteau en terre n'est pas les
deux salles du collège lapierre mais là
maintenant je suis là bas c'était pareil
vélo même virus ne s'agit plus mais une
fois encore l'entreprise ne peut
supporter la concurrence
la production est insuffisante en
quantité et les procédés d'extraction
trop archaïque pour cause de non
rentabilité
l'exploitation des salines cesse
définitivement en 1972
[Musique]
l'activité je pense artisanale sur ce
site la star était au début des années
70 est en fait le site c'est pas mal
dégradé et puis il ya eu apparemment des
projets de spéculation immobilière
relativement à cet endroit qui n'était
plus valorisées sur lesquels ils avaient
plus d'usagers et donc le conservateur
du littoral s'est rendu acquéreur d'une
partie du site d'une manière un peu
brutale puisque c'est dans le cadre
d'une procédure d'expropriation devons
la beauté et la qualité environnementale
du lieu une procédure de déclaration
d'utilité publique est engagée par le
conservatoire du littoral
celui ci en devient propriétaire en 1980
et le fait classer par décret en 1988
l'idée c'est de concilier une pratique
artisanale patrimoniale on va dire avec
la qualité écologique d'un site dès lors
des travaux de nettoyage et
d'aménagement sont engagés avec pour
objectifs principaux la réhabilitation
des salines et la sauvegarde du milieu
naturel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une remise en activité de l'exploitation
a même été effective de 1996 à 2001
mais pour des raisons financières elle
se soldera par un échec
depuis la production de sel bien que
plus modeste continue
[Musique]
enfin un partenariat est mis en place
pour reprendre l'exploitation du sel
réunionnais en vue d'une production de
qualité dans le cadre d'un projet
original la création d'un musée du sel
n'avait de sens que si les salines été
remise en route
le musée du sel est une annexe du muséum
le fonctionnement est géré par le muséum
d'histoire naturelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les personnes qui travaillent sur les
sur le site bien souvent ils ont eu des
ancêtres qui ont travaillé sur le site
donc c'est ça représente quand même
quelque chose d'important pour eux c'est
leur patrimoine 1 c'est le seul endroit
où l'on produit du sel pour la réunion
le sel de saint leu a quand même une
réputation là on peut dire international
même au niveau de sa qualité et le
réseau tourisme est chargé de en fin de
compte de la production de seine la
commercialisation du set
ce site était là avant pour produire du
sel point final donc il ya toujours
cette partie là mais c'est surtout le
côté pédagogique est importante
nous a semblé intéressant avec le
conservatoire du littoral et le conseil
général d'enfer je dirais une quelque
chose de pédagogique
d'une manière générale il est important
de qu'il y ait une appropriation de
l'histoire il faut qu'on garde la
mémoire donc cette appropriation par par
chaque réunionnais est fondamental de ce
qui est intéressant la pointe au sel
c'est qu'on est en train de faire du sel
sur un endroit qui s'y prêtent
on a une pratique humaine qui est
complètement collés qui est complètement
a assujetti complètement incohérent avec
un site naturel à la pointe au sel
le conservateur du littoral fixe un
cadre l'initient une réflexion il initie
une éthique il initie un projet il le
peaufine le négociant avec les
différents partenaires concernés
et puis après une fois que le projet
était défini le conservatoire du
littoral aide et pilote sa réalisation
financière et après ils en délègue le
fonctionnement ou collectivités
territoriales donc là sur ce site là
très concrètement on a d'ores et déjà le
conseil général qui intervient via deux
de ses directions la direction la
promotion culturelle et sportive de la
direction de l'environnement et de
l'énergie
on a également l'office de tourisme de
saint leu qui intervient pour assurer le
fonctionnement des salins
[Musique]
si on est sur une pointe très exposée à
un brouillard salin important et ça va
générer pour nous des choix de matériaux
c'est à dire que le choix de la
couverture en cuivre qui n'existait pas
à l'origine a été dictée par la volonté
de créer quelque chose de relativement
durable et l'intérêt de ce matériau en
plus c'est qu'il prend une patine dans
le temps avec eux il prend une couleur
verte qui était intéressante par rapport
à ceux ci dans ses entrepôts en stocker
du sel il y avait de la saumure il y
avait des résidus humide un clip qui
pouvaient se s'évacuer donc on avait le
sol qui était bombay en périphérie du
bâtiment on avait des petits tuyaux en
cuivre dans le soubassement qui
permettait d'évacuer cette saumure à
l'extérieur on a essayé de garder
l'histoire de ces éléments-là en
réintroduisant des tubes en cuivre dans
les bas de murs dans lesquels on a mis
des petites diodes électro luminescentes
pour marquer le cheminement du bâtiment
et marquer son soubassement que
l'objectif c'est non pas que se soit
amusé d'un au sens ancien du terme et
que ce soit quelque chose de vivant
donc il doit être il doit être en
relation avec les salines qui sont en
activité
l'idée c'était de garder l'authenticité
de garder le jus d'origine de ces
bâtiments en réutilisant les matériaux
qui préexistait c'est à dire les pierres
de taille toutes les maçonneries
moellons on a ouvert le bâtiment côté
montagne pour le protéger des embruns
côté mer donc les quelques ouvertures
qu'on a créé pour que le bâtiment soit
exploitable les a faits vers stella donc
ça donne des visions vert vert
mieux qu'ils soient un peu au dessus à
travers ce partenariat fructueux
le musée du sel permet aujourd'hui la
renaissance des salines et rajoute un
nouveau chapitre à la longue histoire de
la pointe au sel
[Musique]